this is the Gothika skink small in size  the Gothika skink  is covered in camouflage skin to blend  in with the alpine rocks they call home  the Gothica skank is native to Victoria  Australia and can only be found in one  area known as the Bois Gong high plains  because they are only found in such a  small area they are vulnerable to  natural disasters such as bush fires but  this isn't the only threat facing the  skinks their habitat has also been  affected by the construction of ski  resorts and the grazing and trampling  from farm animals but their biggest  threat is climate change warmer  temperatures have allowed new predators  once kept at bay by the cold into their  previously isolated habitat zoos  Victoria have been working on a breeding  program to ensure the preservation of  this species and a rescue and recovery  program if there is an immediate threat  to the wild population this is the  Gothika skink